collectif Curie de parc Aix ça pourrait
ressembler à un nom de groupe musical
mais non c'est plutôt le nom d'un projet
fou mené par cette femme de coeur
Leonora je suis encore au travail
communautaire je suis aussi chercheuse
postura et là je travaille avec mes
intervention programme pour le demandeur
d'asile
cette belle histoire commence pendant la
pandémie au printemps 2021 la Stephen
était fermé cette année cuisinier à la
maison moi je voulais acheter des repas
de femmes donc j'ai juste envoyé une
courriel juste à mes amis mais mon
réseau puis la réponse était comme 100%
oui on achète le repas de cette femme là
ces femmes ce sont des demandeuses
d'asile pour la plupart originaires du
Penjab région du sous-continent indien
c'est une population moi je trouve qui
sont le plus vulnérables ici et la
plupart ils sont les mers avec les
enfants à la maison
fait comme ça et puis cuisiner cuisiner
avec l'amour fait un peu d'argent et
nourrir les gens à Montréal
c'est ainsi que Leonora a créé collectif
Curie de parcs un service de
distribution alimentaire des plats
cuisinés par une dizaine de femmes comme
tarangit qui habite dans le Parc
Extension quartier multiethnique de
Montréal
enchanté
elle cuisinée pour nous depuis avril 20
21 donc cuisine chaque semaine presque
ça c'est sa fille c'est la cuisinière
[Rires]
pour se faire un peu d'argent parce que
c'est difficile il fasse beaucoup
d'obstacles pas juste emploi mais
immigration la langue tout ça sticks va
être
cuisine aujourd'hui un curry de pois
chiches
interagittes beaucoup de femmes de
l'Inde en fait et ils sont tous des très
bonnes chefs
[Musique]
cette femme de 70 ans vit à Montréal
depuis 5 ans
il flotte une agréable odeur d'épices
dans la cuisine aujourd'hui la cuisiner
matin
dans une sauce tomate oignon avec le
petit pois
ça c'est les pains à l'ail qu'elle a
préparé les chapeaux
en plus de vendre des plats en format
individuel l'organisme offre aussi un
service de traiteur pouvant accommoder
jusqu'à 100 personnes et il est aussi
possible de commander des plats qui
seront ensuite offerts à des gens dans
le besoin dans la communauté
[Musique]
c'est bon Paris merci beaucoup parvine
de nous avoir invité dans votre cuisine
c'est dans ce café communautaire en
plein coeur de Parc Extension que
Leonora prépare les commandes qui seront
livrées par des bénévoles j'ai 4
livraisons et je vais donner le choix de
faire si tu veux je peux faire les deux
dans Parc Extension puis celles sur
Outils le plateau j'ai d'abord commandé
des repas et puis après ça je savais
qu'il y avait des
bénévoles et puis j'ai enfin mes
services je pense j'ai été impressionné
une jeune femme qui met autant d'énergie
pour créer et un organisation comme ça
une infrastructure et ça fonctionne très
bien et là si collectif curry continue à
prendre de l'ampleur comme ça vous
faites quoi et là je vois comment les
femmes sont très contentes cuisinées les
clients adorent ça fait que j'ai pas le
choix j'ai pas le choix de continuer
même si j'ai d'autres emplois j'ai des
bénévoles maintenant j'ai les gens qui
m'aident et bien seulement j'espère que
les femmes aussi quand il va avoir le
papier il peut aussi prendre plus de
responsabilités pour gérer les collecter
vous savez commenter
et j'ai mis un petit merci pour votre
soutien est-ce que ça vous apporte à
vous mais moi j'ai pas de famille c'est
ce fameux on prend soin de des autres
mais aussi je vois ma mère dans cette
femme-là parce que ma mère a vécu ça
mais sans soutien sans le réseau donc je
me sentais avec tous les sapés unités
que moi j'ai maintenant moi je peux
redonner je me sens obligée en plus de
redonner donc pour moi c'est naturel de
le faire